uh hi everybody thanks for the nice
introduction
uh before uh i start uh
i would like to thank to thermo fisher
sciences and
lab roots for enabling this virtual
event
as you see uh from my title i will my
talk will focus on the noble mechanisms
of
endocrine resistance in breast cancer
just a brief introduction breast cancer
used to be
considered as a single disease but with
the progression of time
it was classified as hormone receptor
positive
or negative mainly estrogen receptor
positive
and then in the late 80s or early 90s
uh the her2 positivity became an
important
marker and especially with the
availability of the her2 positive
therapies it became a key player
and with the advent of the mobile
technology such as microarrays
usually around 2000 then the
molecular classification came into the
scene and mostly four different subtypes
two of them are estrogen receptor
positive liminal a
and b and her2 positive or her2
enriched or basal like carcinoma
so this new novel technologies
mainly marker arrays also led to the
novel rna-based prognostic tools and
with that uh mamaprint
is one of the earliest funds and
oncotype dx
they are based either microarray or qrt
pcr but due to the time constraints i
will only focus the oncotype dx which is
uh the widely used in the clinical
setting at least in the us
so uh as you see from here um
it is a recurrence score essay meaning
that predicts the
uh the likelihood of recurrence score
and then based on the proliferation
genes mostly
specific to er positive her2 negative
early breast cancer
you can see here some estrogen related
genes
and invasion or her2 also in there
the main thing is this test it
classifies
er positive breast cancer into three
groups
mainly low risk intermediate risk and
high risk
and if you look at the kaplan-meier plot
you can see that the loris patients
really do good so very good prognosis
the high risk is always aggressive and
also
pre-prognosis therefore and intermediate
group on the other hand in between and
we don't know
which one will recur and which one not
so this led the
designing of the taylor rx clinical
trial
may need to determine the role of
chemotherapy in
intermediate score group and then
whether it's useful or not that is
mostly
important and if you look at the um
kaplan-meier plots uh there are two
groups
mainly uh the group that uh chemotherapy
and endocrine therapy together given uh
this is a randomized trial
and endocrine therapy alone if you look
at those curves either invasive disease
pre-survival or overall
pre-survival coupled meyer plots we
don't see
a difference at all so meaning that um
the uh low risk patients and then
the intermediaries patients
which makes about 70 of the patients
do not benefit from chemotherapy but
they may develop recurrences so
therefore
it is necessary to develop normal
targets beyond
uh proliferation and prevent these
recurrences in this patient group
so a little bit back to the basics uh as
you know there are
uh multi-layer molecular regulatory
levels
uh dna level rna level protein and
networks so the kind of
uh early studies focus on the dna mostly
mutations
but with the advent of mobile
technologies like
next-gen sequencing and microarrays
mainly advanced
microarrays i would say like chlorine d
we can look at the into details of the
rna regulation
like alternative splicing events or
even non-coding rnas and so forth
and there are some studies of course at
the protein level and different drugable
pathways but most of the state is mainly
dna and rna which i would like
briefly go over so
one of the pillars of the breast cancer
research is
the tcga network analysis usually from
the frozen
tumors not only for prey for everything
every cancer that is
than cancer but here for the breast
cancer
uh you can see that at the mutation
level
um here are the uh mainly these are the
major mutations that is classified based
of the molecular subtypes on the
left side that i mentioned before and
then
they combine the clinical data uh like
tumor size
node positivity negativity and also copy
number status
if you look all of these parameters
actually uh one take home message from
this
study is most mutations are infrequent
you can see uh mainly the 3 3 a in the
left hand side and tp 53
these are the most frequent ones in all
groups 36 percent or 37 percent
respectively
but if you look at the all other
mutations you can see the numbers three
percent two percent one percent
meaning infrequent that of course
makes the randomized trials uh to very
difficult because usually they are
targeting the um because of the power if
analysis larger
subgroups and therefore
well mutations are not only the only
factor probably and
giving the infrequency let's go to the
rna level
and then um we decided to especially do
transcriptome analysis
and uh try to find out normal mechanisms
that can go beyond the um
proliferation-based genes
so we started we started to look at the
metabrick data set this is also another
pillar uh
cohort analysis in breast cancer
mainly uh dated integrated analysis of
copy number and gene expression of 2000
breast tumors which is a a
big uh tri a big size and then
if you look at the left hand side uh
this study
uh classified the breast
tumors into 10 different integrative
clusters so you can see in different
colors all of these based on the bad
prognosis good prognosis
but since our focus is er positive
subtypes i would
like to focus on the right hand side
which is the um the cluster three and
seven the clustering is the red color
which is uh considering the
better prognosis while the cluster seven
is a poor prognosis
so we looked at the expression data of
those clusters
and then end up with three different uh
differential expression accumulated on
those three different
chromosomes mainly chromosome one
chromosome
eight and sixteen so it wasn't very
surprising that much because those
chromosomes are heavily uh suggested in
cancer including breast cancer
regulation
but we identified those two genes uh
being in chromosome 8 esrp one
and chromosomes 16 esrp2 these are
associated
genes and then they are upregulated
in those patient groups that approve
patient groups which cluster seven
so it's just a brief um
introduction what is epithelial splicing
regulatory protein
actually they are rna binding proteins
and they are
splicing factors so in the literature
first uh identified as a functional
importance for epithelial design
chemical transition emt
control splicing of those genes and
wrigley's alternative splicing events
mostly cassette exons
however it was not at that time
available the biological relevance in
breast cancer and clinical outcomes so
we decided to pursue that
here you can see on the left-hand side
the couple of meyer plots
what we did actually we use the data
sets
uh for both uh microarray
based so the first four uh plot
is actually um the first two at the
top uh is the uh breast mark on line two
which comprises 26
data sets of breast cancers and derived
from 12 different microarray platforms
including the epimetrics early arrays of
u133
and others and then you can see that if
you look at the er positive versus er
negative
the red the high esrp one expression
is highly correlated with poor prognosis
in
er positive but not in er negative
if you look at the uh the bottom two
plots uh
which is the tcga and breast tumor that
i mentioned
really we looked at again the esr p1
expression in er positive negative and
we verified that
it is important in er positive group
rather than er negative
so the another thing we looked actually
since we are focused on the uh
resistance to endocrine therapies what
does it mean in terms of
tamoxifen treatment which was available
uh data
and then chemotherapy and you can see in
the middle uh panel
it is highly associated the high
overexpression with
uh tamoxifen therapy resistance
but if you look at that it doesn't do
any difference with the chemotherapy so
this kind of
further verified that it is important in
actually resistant
mechanisms and if you look at the on the
right hand side
we wanted to look some cohort with the
oncotype dx scores available
and with this you can see both esr p1
and esrp2
it is highly expressed significantly in
the
high score high risk group intermediate
yes little bit trendy but it is not
significant
compared to the lower group and by the
way i'm not showing the esrp 2 because
it was not significant in all of the
groups so
we focused the further analysis to esrp
one only
and then uh next we decided to use some
acquired resistant
uh models preclinical models to
endocrine therapy
these are mcf7 based therapies lcc2
which is thomas fan resistance lcc 9
full western and also into tamoxifen
these are the
main standard of care therapies for
endocrine therapy in the clinical
setting
and we stably knock down esrp-1 gene in
those
cell models using the antiviral
transduction system we later use crispr
so we verified it
and here um we have successes we've
shown that
the um esrp one knockdown in the
upper left side both at the rna
level and protein that will be knocked
down it very
successfully and then you can see the
different clones which chose one of the
clones to further continue with the
in nitro and in meteor analyses so in
the right hand side
top and bottom you can see this cell
density and
cell viability essays that we have tried
different
essays the main message is if you look
at that
with the knockdown you can see a
decrease in the cell growth
including tamoxifen estrogen treatment
and all
is further the treatment but it
decreases the cell growth
and if you look at the individual on the
lower uh left side uh for the both
models of resistance
you can see that the esrp one knocked
down
it can block the cell growth reduce it
significantly or block
the tumor growth also in evo
so next we decided to look at the
alternative splicing event as i
mentioned the esrp one is
oh it makes sense uh it will change to
some of the alternative splicing events
in these
uh models and here just a brief
background
as you know uh in the constitution of
splicing the introns are removed to form
the
mature messenger rna and usually these
are
very tightly regulated process exons
always
neither uh removed or included at the
same
locations uh however ovarian
transpiration
aberrant splicing events happens and
then it may cause diseases like cancer
and
others so briefly uh the events
uh the exons can be excluded or included
like
cassette exomes it can be more than one
exon
excluded or included or the splicing can
occurs in the five prime
splice side or three primed you can have
a very
long or short exon and
of course introns can be retained so
according to the literature the esrp one
mostly involved in the regulation of the
cathedrals
here is a schematics uh showing that uh
one of the scenarios or
implicated in the literature that uh
the esrp one regulation uh of splicing
can be esr1 motif dependent or
independent in the case of the motif
dependent
you can see that the motif can be
upstream of an exon
then the axon is skipped if it's within
the exon
or downstream of the exon the exon is
included so this is of course if the in
in esr from modded involved but there is
independent motive
once but it's very complex so i don't
want to go into detail
here uh then we decided to look at the
alternative splicing events using the
human transcriptome array hta2 which is
the previous version of the clearing t
and you can see uh the donut
plots here showing different uh
different levels the circle shows
different levels of
[Music]
gene level or alternative splicing level
changes and then the first two uh
includes the all the genes and
alternative splicing events the middle
two is significant ones and the
the last two representative of the
frequencies of the
uh the alternative splicing events with
esrp motifs
and also correlated genes
and the um level looking at the volcanic
plots here
we see similar upregulation and down
regulation of the genes at the gene
level
and then of course we wanted to look
uh first at the emtgs because it has
been well defined that
esr p1 is important for the emt genes
splicing and then here's a
structural view from the tag transcript
from
analysis console uh of the hta
and you can see that uh each of the
boxes actually representative of probe
selection regions psrs
the highlighted blue shows the changes
within the given
[Music]
genes and then you can see either
down or up inclusion or exclusion for
the given
locations of the psrs if you look at the
big picture these are the 10 genes that
have been
shown before important for the esr p1
function and here the second column
shows the watches and carson's group
which they first defined the locations
of the chromosomal chromosomes
where the exxon events happened
cassette exons and then here the third
one is or
location which is exactly the same
locations
we have observed uh most of them
same exxon skipping or inclusion
by two different methods actually we
used previously
rna sequencing for those knockdown
models and we use the hda so more or
less
similar results but sometimes we haven't
seen some
consistent results with the rna
sequencing giving that
the depth coverage as you know
may have some bias on the rna sequencing
whereas the
hda is independent of that because of
the prop
based essay so
next we further look to what kind of
mechanisms are
involved in the knockdown besides
proliferation genes that we are looking
for
so uh to our uh interest the metabolic
path-based genes were
reduced in terms of esrp knockdown here
you can see the
protein analysis that uh mostly fast
and scd-1 and phdgs these are the
important genes in metabolic pathways
you can see in the tamoxifen resistant
gene when it's locked down to c3 column
uh
most of them gone or maybe a little bit
down with the poisson with the
fluorescent group 9c2
column you can see also down with the
knockdown
while the time of span once is more
significant compared that
then we looked at the seahorse metabolic
assays
because it's one of the ways to use it
in in vitro
readout and you can see on the right
hand
side if you look at the middle panel uh
if you look there are two different
energy phenotypes
either the glycolytic capacity or
the um the micro
mitochondrial respiration mechanism
which is
indicated for oxidative phosphorylation
and looking at the sphere respiratory
capacity
in terms of glycolytic capacity we
didn't see
uh so much change in both of the models
if you look at the sphere respiratory
capacity at the bottom we see
the knockdown increased mostly in the
thermosphere resistant bottle but not in
the
fulbestrum resistant model
so uh of course we also looked at the
alternative splicing events
in terms of these metabolic pathway
genes in esrp
knockdown models if you look at the top
three
fascinating acd and phdh
we have seen at the location locations
shown
uh the inclusion of these
exons in both of the models
consistently there are some others that
they confirmed that it has been shown in
the
in the esr p1 splicing like cd44
and fgr1 and 2 so it's consists that we
are seeing those changes too
so one thing i would like to emphasize
is of course the phenotype change
because
uh for the emt genes we have seen the
same
exact splicing events but we haven't
seen
any phenotype of the emt so therefore
uh we are not focusing on the amp
teachings but
we continued with the um splicing
of those
so okay what does it mean in terms of
the
relevance of alternative splicing events
and esrp one in er
positive breast cancer so as i mentioned
uh current therapies include endocrine
therapy and we have identified esrp one
is one of the
markers of resistance and uh
both tamoxifen and progesterone so how
do we go forward
this for the clinical setting the
cdk46 inhibitors these are a new set of
uh
drugs that is uh becoming a standard
care of therapy in the endocrine
resistance so these are uh
very uh important especially uh it
showed a
longer progression free survival in
patients with endocrine therapy
resistance patients like
um 8 10 months but still
overall survival is needs to be worked
out so of course we wanted to know
whether
um the esr p1 knockdown
can be behaved like like if we use these
inhibitors
we can take care of the esr pi srp1
signaling uh and reduce the um or
prevent the endocrine
resistance
so um what we did actually uh
using the clear md essay uh we wanted to
look at the uh both in gene level and
transcriptable level
what kind of uh differences we are
seeing especially
you know i've shown uh the differences
based on the transcript
analysis of esrp one markdown
and then we want to see if we
use the same endocrine resistance
cells and treat with a bms eclipse a
member clip is usually uh
originally developed by a lily and
in clinical use fda approved but we use
the
optimistic from select and so
we decided to do the clearing essay and
here you can see by the
venn diagram what are the common
genes and what are the unique genes to
each of the
treatment or knockdown so we have
found 77 overlapping genes
that are both changed based on the
knockdown or abomasic
treatment and you will get these
pathways
and it is usually cell cycle and mitosis
and dna repair
which is expected so our mystic lip is a
cdk46 inhibitor
and if you look at further unique genes
on the other hand uh you can see further
cell cycle checkpoints dna replication
so it's a huge
induct uh these pathways are coming with
the
treatment if you look at the esrp one
macdon on the other hand
we see a unique uh group
metabolism and close cholesterol
biosynthesis
so which is not taking care of the other
mystically
so what does this mean mainly uh
if you look at the esrp1 uh both
proliferation
and metabolism genes are regulated and
if you knock down
you can take care of both mechanisms so
dual inhibition of these mechanisms
if you only treat with abemi cyclip
alone
on the other hand we only take care of
the proliferation based genes
and it doesn't do anything to the
metabolic part phase
if you add tamoxifen to it so you don't
see any difference so it doesn't do
anything
so that uh kind of suggests that we also
need to
block the metabolism derived
pathways in addition to the
proliferation pathways
with that mind we did couple of
comprehensive
essays mainly this is the
integrated analysis of transcriptomics
and
proteomics uh if you look at the
individually
the previously i shown that we did the
um
hda essay with the gene level
alternative splicing level
uh in response to the macdon which a and
b
when did they we did this rip chip
essays mainly
rna in the precipitation chip in this
sense
we combined ironing in the presentation
with the clearing view
declaring the microarray and then looked
at the
same gene levels and splicing levels
and we also used the inner precipitation
proteomic
assays so we combined all of these
essays together
and to find out what are the main
genes that are interacting with esrp1
because esr p1 is also an rna binding
protein
so we wanted to see what kind of rnas
are binding to esrp one that we can
further
continue with these genes in terms of
metabolic genes i'm talking
and next here you can see the detailed
view of the
rna immunoprecipitation uh clearing the
sa
uh here you can see the uh that is
specific to the
uh knockdown rather than the iggs and
if you look at the venn diagram the
genes that are specific uh to uh
endocrine resistance cell line coming up
in order to narrow down 140
genes we did these integrative analysis
and then uh come up with esr p1 and
phdgh
the most important genes to further
uh focus on the right hand side
the upper corner we also did the rna
immunization
and rtq pcr to verify the results from
the rna clarium d
essay so which is very verified
and uh we also look at the uh messenger
instability
uh in response to esrp one knock down
you can see on the left side
uh esrp one uh stability is uh
half life is reduced uh with the
yes sir srp one macdon is expected but
it also affects the phd phdh
as messenger and instability you can see
from three hours
to in almost less than
an hour and all as you see with the gap
th we don't see any difference which
used as a
control of course we also did the
phd gh knockdown for these cell lines
and here on the upper side you see the
chlorogenic
assays for the um tamoxifen resistant
cell lines
this time we also use a non-acquired uh
resistance cell line which is t470 in
that case which has
uh aggressive but it's not the acquired
resistance model
so we can see some uh proliferation
reduction
cell growth reduction in collogenic
essays
but these are 2d essays so we are
planning to write right in the process
of doing the indivo essays to see the
real impact on the
tumor growth and we also
looked at the seahorse essays for the
metabolic
readouts and you can see on the upper
the endocrine resistant cell line versus
phds knocked down
in terms of the glycolysis
we don't we see some decrease
but with the uh base
sphere respiratory capacity which is
more oxidative phosphorylation
representative we see a huge increase
with the
knockdown which is uh confirming the
results like the esrp one
knockdown model on the other hand with
the t470 model we don't see
those so we would like to see whether it
is an acquired resistance versus
non-occurring resistant um difference so
we are continuing uh to further
understand
uh the role in those models
so with that uh uh i would like to
conclude
and uh my take-home message is i've used
uh
transcriptome analysis in different uh
settings so as i uh mentioned first we
used in the clinical setting
using uh genomic data sets
microarrays or all rna sequencing
available sets for from
tumors breast cancers breast tumors we
use
those to identify or
target with clinical outcome
it's very important to find out to be
event from the pet's
bedside because you need to see
something that is important
challenging in the clinical setting and
then we took it to our
preclinical models and used the
transcriptomic
analysis to understand the differences
at the gene level and alternative
splicing
level and then we used
a besides discovery approach we use it
as a targeted approach
and to see whether the impact of in esr
p1 the knockdown using the not down
the interval vectors converges to the
drugs because you can use these
vectors in the clinical setting so
whether the
the current drugs are able to uh
overcome
those affects and
used those and compared and came up with
a
new um target pathway
which is metabolism because uh right now
mostly proliferation is taking care of
the standard of care therapies but
metabolism is still a
question how to do it so we use those
techniques to target a metabolic part
phase
and then we are suggesting that
targeting metabolic pathways in addition
to the proliferation
might provide a noble uh way for
controlling the endocrine resistance
in breast cancer and we are we would
like to
in the future try other drugs to target
metabolism together with the
proliferation
in that i conclude and i would like to
thank my
lab members and my collaborators at iu
and outside iiu and also tama fisher
group
especially for their help in both hta
and clear india
thank you so much